اقتحموا اقتحموا اقتحموا يا شباب يا ساتر
يا
الله ينشطون في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
وقطاع غزه وتعد اداه محوريه في حرب
المدن
وحدات سريه خاصه عناصرها يشبهون العرب
يتحدثون بلسانهم ويندس بينهم لجمع
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه او للانقضاض على
الفلسطينيين عنفا واعتداء
واعتقالاً العامله في يهودا
والسامره الذين يعرفون كيف يظهرون في وسط
جنين
ونابلس ويبدون مثل العرب عليهم ان يفهموا
الثقافه والعقليه وعليهم ان يفهموا
القران المستعربون المتخفون في العمليه او
في الاتصالات اللاسلكيه يدعون
الملونين اما الجنود الذين يرتدون الزيه
الرسميه فيدع
الملون هم العناصر المتخفيه التي تشرع في
الهجوم والخضر هم قوه
الدعم دخل قوات اول شي قوات
مستعربه بحاصل المنطقه بعدين بشع الجيش
لهم حمايه بعمل زي طوق ام عليها على
المنطقه المحاصره بعت القناصات اصح
المنازل النار على كل شي يتحرك
يعني
ما امكانيه ملاحقه هؤلاء دوليا خاصه ان
هذه العمليات لا تتم الا بغطاء رسمي كبير
بموجب قانون الولايات المتحده هناك قانون
يحضر تقديم مساعده امنيه لدول اخرى
وتحديدا لوحدات قوات الامن التي تتوفر
معلومات موثوقه على ضلوعها في انتهاكات
صارخه لحقوق الانسان بناء على البيانات
التي جمعناها خلال سنوات من العمل وفي
الغالبيه العظمى من الحالات لم نرى احدا
يتعرض
للمسائله حرب المدن التي تشنها اسرائيل
عبر المستعربين تواجه وعيا فلسطينيا
باساليب وتضع المستعرب في حاله خوف وترقب
دائم وصلت الى وضع بالغ الصعوبه اوشكت فيه
على قتل نفسي فعلا هناك من اصدقائي من
قتلوا انفسهم واحدهم ادخل المستشفى اثر
اصابته
بالجنون رغم استراتيجيات عمليات وحده
تربين العسكريه والاستخبارات السريه لقمع
الفلسطينيين الا ان هذه العمليات باءت
بالفشل في احيان كثيره وتمكن الفلسطينيون
من ايجاد وسائلهم الخاصه لتخطي هذه
الاستراتيجيات التي لا تزال خارج المسائله
القانونيه ومحاسبه المجتمع الدولي رغم
توصيف بعضها كجرائم
[موسيقى]
حرب